- Oh, my gosh, this is a great question.
(inhales deeply)
(groans)
In that moment, I was like,
yep, this could be it.
For many years, I felt outside
the loop on understanding.
(claps)
Let's get started. (hard exhale)
My favorite videos I've
ever worked on are...
(camera flashes)
Hey, everyone, I am sick.
But I am dedicated to this Q + A,
because I have gotten literally thousands
of questions from you
and I'm going to answer
not every single one,
but a lot of them, today.
Let's do this.
- Can I ask you a question?
(uptempo music)
- We have a delivery.
- Just cause you, you really sound bad.
- "Fire Cider," literally
has habanero peppers!
All right, (moans) fire cider.
(gulps)
(grunts on exhale)
Well, if that doesn't cure
me, I don't know what will.
What's question number one? (sniffs)
What are the top three
countries I have visited,
ranked by cuisine?
Ooh, that's a good question. Um...
(groans) I hate tops
because it always means I have
to, like, choose the best.
Let me just give some
top three that aren't
THE top three.
Taiwan,
Taiwan.
Taiwan's street food is so amazing.
It is optimized for convenience
and deliciousness and speed.
And one of the things I
love about food is when
you order it and then
it comes moments later.
And in Taiwan, that happens. It's amazing.
Northern Italy, because I
haven't been to Southern Italy,
so I can't speak for Southern Italy.
But Northern Italy cuisine is excellent,
amazing, and very special.
Number three, Northern Mexico.
Northern Mexico near
Tijuana and Mexicali have
some of the best tacos
on the earth, in my opinion.
Carne asada on tortillas de harina
that are so delicious.
That is my favorite.
Do you ever unplug? How
do you manage to take care
of your mental well-being as a journalist?
I mean, clearly I'm not
doing great. (scoffs)
- Most of these people are
not ready to be unplugged.
- I do unplug. This year,
I have been unplugging less
because we are sort of in a
sprint in a lot of things.
Bright Trip is sprinting, we're building,
we're scaling Bright Trip.
We're scaling my channel,
making a lot of content.
So I have not been unplugging.
And I'm sort of paying the price.
♪ Hello darkness, my old friend ♪
In terms of unplugging from the news
and unplugging from global events,
I'm actually quite unplugged.
A couple of years ago, I made a decision
to not be constantly, deeply
involved in the news cycle.
It was one of the best
decisions I made in my life.
I follow the news, but I
don't follow the daily news.
I read the news once a week
and it is "The Economist"
and other publications,
but I only let it come
into my life once a week.
And I'm not following Twitter,
I'm not following any feeds,
Apple News, any of that.
So that is a big part
of my mental wellbeing,
is being informed without having to feel
the constant buzz of, of daily news.
(swish)
What's the first effect in
After Effects that you learned,
and what made you want to learn it?
Oh, my gosh,
this is a great question.
So, for those of you who don't know,
After Effects is the
animation program I've used
since 2012 to make animations,
Maps, and motion graphics, all of it.
The first effect that I ever
learned in After Effects was
trim paths.
Trim paths is a way of drawing on a shape
so that it goes from not
being there to drawing on.
And the first thing I
ever drew on was this owl.
(swish)
(owl hoots)
This owl was the first
animation I ever made.
The owl draws on and then it drops.
And it's just my first
animation I've ever did.
- Good job, little buddy.
(audience laughs)
- Oh, man, you've got to start somewhere.
That was a good question.
- Some honey...
- Bless your heart.
- ...at the bottom so you need to stir it.
Man, I am very well taken care of.
Okay. Since Is is clearly
here, let's give Is a mic
and she's going to ask
the rest of the questions.
- Look at me.
- Sure
- I'm the captain now.
- [Is] What are the top three videos
you've worked on, ever?
- Ooh, man. How do I even
answer that question?
- You must choose,
but choose wisely.
- My favorite videos I've
ever worked on are...
I think this one I made a years ago
about why so many people go to Iceland,
like tourism in Iceland.
(splutters)
- Why does everyone come to Iceland?
- That was the first
time that I had gone out
not as Vox or just not as anyone,
as me, to make an explainer
and to do it in the field.
And it was really fun.
We were sort of just going around Iceland
just for this random
trip, and I just sort of
made this video about why
people went to Iceland.
And there was this one moment
when I'm on this black sand
beach in Southern Iceland,
and I was like, what if I drew
the graph on the black
sand with a drone shot
and I just animate over the drone shot?
And it was this fun moment.
And then I did, and it just worked out,
and then it was like,
we're in the blue lagoon
and there was no one there.
And it was just like, just
the perfect little thing
and the explanation came
together really nicely.
The second one, I would say, is when I did
Hong Kong, China for, for "Borders"
and went into China
through, and we had to wait in the border.
I had to go through this border patrol
scene that took forever.
And then I made it into China
and I just had this adventure in China.
And that was a really
amazing experience for me.
And it was a story that I was drinking up.
I just, I couldn't get
enough of this story.
Another "Borders" season one episode
that was a favorite of mine
is when I went to the island
of Svalbard up in north of Norway,
to this island that's
owned by 90 countries,
but it's controlled by Norway.
I went on a boat and went
to this, this village,
this Russian village on this island.
And it's Russia just has people there
just so that they can say
they have people there.
And they run this coal mining operation
that loses money but it doesn't matter.
It's like, that was such a wild place.
I was all alone in this, in this village.
So those are some of my favorites.
Those were really good videos.
- [Is] What motivated
you to go to therapy?
Did you have any initial resistance?
How has it impacted how
you show up as a partner,
father, and in your
relationship with yourself?
- Wow.
- I started going to therapy
a year and a half ago.
I was resistant. I thought
going to therapy was
a thing that you did for six weeks
to sort of get fixed
and then you're better.
And I sort of approached it in that way.
After the first couple of
sessions, I was like, so
why did we just talk
for those two sessions?
Why didn't we get to the,
you know, the hard stuff.
And I quickly realized that
therapy is actually coaching.
It's like, it's like having a teacher
to teach you how to develop
new skills in your mind
and in your relationships.
Like playing piano or
learning a new language,
you have to practice.
And usually having a teacher
helps you practice in the right way.
Over the past year and a half,
I've learned a lot about my mind,
about my insecurities,
about my behavior and where it comes from
and how it's linked to
other parts of my life.
More importantly, I've
learned a lot about patterns,
patterns in my relationships
that are just cycles that just happen.
And they happen unconsciously to me.
But as soon as you are with
a trained professional,
talking about your relationship,
you see those patterns and you're like,
oh, these patterns aren't actually
what I want in my relationship.
And here's how to change them.
That's a hard process,
it takes a long time, like any new skill,
but, man, it is, has changed my life.
It's changed the way I think,
it's changed my relationship with Is,
it's changed my relationship with my boys,
it's changed my relationship
with my parents,
it has changed all my relationships.
And of course it has.
I have new skills that
I didn't have before.
I wish therapy was more accessible
and more available to people
than it is in this country, at least.
I'm glad that this
conversation is normalizing it
a little bit more and
I'm grateful for therapy.
Good question.
(slurps tea)
- [Is] Have you ever felt
like your life was in danger
during a visit in a foreign country?
(dial-up sounds)
(ding)
- Yes.
So in 2010, I was hiking up a volcano
in Guatemala with my little brother
and a guy popped out of
the bushes with a gun
and pointed it at my head.
In that moment, I was like,
yep, this could be it.
He just wanted to steal our stuff.
I don't think there was any scenario
in which he would
actually pull the trigger.
And I'm sure that gun wasn't even loaded
now that I see it now.
But in that moment it felt very scary,
but that was about it.
I think the other, the only other one was
when I was driving up
these mountains in Nepal
on these really sketchy roads.
And there were just huge
drops left and right.
Yeah, that's about it.
- [Is] What is one topic
you wish to explore
but you don't think you'll
be able to make a video on?
- A topic I really want to
explore is climate change.
And yet, every time I think about it
or every time I hear
about it or read about it,
there's this sort of, I think there's this
collective apathy that humans
have about climate change
because it's so incredibly invisible
until it's not.
It's so incredibly slow until it's not.
And it's so incredibly
widespread, the causes.
And, and, and so, I am always scheming on
how can I bring climate change
to life and make it real?
I don't know how to do that.
Hopefully, someday I'll,
I'll crack the code on that
but I've been stumped time and time again
on how to make climate change,
which is a very real
dooming thing, come to life.
Because right now it's a lot of data
and it's a lot of squishy,
extreme weather patterns,
and it's just stuff that, that is hard to,
to really communicate to a big audience,
but I'll get there.
- [Is] Do you travel with your children?
If yes, what is their favorite thing
about traveling so much?
- I do travel with my children.
We've made it a point to
travel with our children
since the very beginning,
which is more complicated
and difficult than traveling
not with your children,
but incredibly gratifying.
When we travel, the
boys like to ride bikes.
We always try to find bikes.
So we'll bike through Amsterdam
or we'll bike through
Florence or whatever.
They love boats and water.
And so, we always find a boat.
So one of our favorite things to do
is rent a boat and just drive it
through a river or a lake somewhere.
I think that it's a
common misconception that
when you travel with kids, you have to
do kids stuff all day.
And yet, we've found a way
to travel with our kids
to make it fun, to go on a hike.
Like we went, we were
in Italy before COVID,
and we went up this mountain
and it was this fun activity,
this adventure that we were all on.
I was having a blast.
We made it a fun thing for the boys too.
And that, that's sort of
been our ethos with travel.
- [Is] What does your
breakfast look like today?
We need an update to that
video for (laughing) 2021.
- Well, I'm making a breakfast update.
So, for those of you don't know,
I made a video called "Why
I Hate American Breakfast."
- I (bleep) hate American breakfast.
- And apparently you all liked it,
and so then I made a follow-up
about what I eat for breakfast
that isn't American breakfast.
And now, I'm working on a video called
"All of the Breakfasts That You Gave Me,"
cause I got so many suggestions,
like Turkish breakfast,
that I am now trying
in my life that I love.
So, my breakfast now is
still a lot of Japanese,
still a lot of hummus, but
I'm starting to branch out
and learn what other breakfasts there are
in the world that I can
integrate into my life.
And I will make a video
about that, I promise.
(swish)
Before we continue, I want
to thank today's sponsor,
which is Policygenius.
Policygenius is not an insurance company.
They are a marketplace
where you can easily
compare life insurance policies.
Life insurance is something
I've started to think about more.
It's something that I think is just wise
for us to have as people
living in this world.
Policygenius makes it
easy to compare quotes
from over a dozen top
insurers, all in one place.
You can save 50% or more on life insurance
by comparing quotes on Policygenius.
You could save $1,300 or more per year
by using Policygenius to
compare life insurance policies.
What I like about Policygenius
is that once you apply,
the Policygenius team
handles all of the paperwork
and scheduling for free.
Another major thing I
love is that Policygenius
doesn't sell my information
to other companies,
which is a very rare thing these days.
And there's no extra hidden
fees anywhere at the process.
It's just clear, smooth, easy, transparent
shopping for life insurance.
I'm thinking more and
more about life insurance
as I'm trying to become
a more responsible adult.
And I'm just, it's not
something that you think about
very often, but it's something
that you can rest easy at night,
knowing that you have life insurance,
in case some emergency happens.
It's for this reason that
Policygenius has gotten
five-star reviews on
Trustpilot and Google.
They just clearly have
really good service.
They make applying for this
stuff easy and very doable.
So head to policygenius.com/johnnyharris
to get started right away.
Thank you, Policygenius,
for sponsoring this video.
Back to the questions.
(swish)
(gulps)
And now we're back and
I've finished my tea.
- I (bleep) love a cup of Rosy.
- All right, what's the next question?
- [Is] How's your Italian
language learning going?
- (groans) No molto bene.
The fact is I am simultaneously
working very hard on piano.
And so I have, I memorized
my thousand words.
I have been speaking
with a local every week,
but I'm like, I wanted to start to do this
and start to really fly,
but I feel like I'm
not, I'm not there yet.
I'm chipping away and I can understand it.
And we were watching a documentary
and there was a bunch of Italian.
I was like, I understand this.
- Well, do you understand?
- Everything except "capeesh."
- But, man, I want to be
so fluent in that language.
- [Is] We're thinking about
doing these videos where
it's like 30 days of jazz piano,
30 days of Italian language,
30 days of swimming every day.
Like, whatever it is
that Johnny is just like,
I want more of that in my life.
So...
(ding)
we'd love suggestions on,
(ding, ding, ding)
on what would be interesting too.
Do we have a plan of Maps
evolving into wallpapers
or wall hangings as Johnny Harris merch?
- Whoa. The answer to that is yes.
I'm actually working on a map right now
that is a physical printed
map that I will be dropping
at some point in coming weeks and months.
- [Is] And there won't be many.
It's like a special
one, once a year, right?
- Yeah.
- [Is] Something like that
- I'm pouring a lot into this map.
And so it's like I'm not going to do
one of these every month.
I'm going to do one of these a year.
It's going to be special.
It's going to be on beautiful paper.
It's going to be everything
I love about Maps
on a map that is printed.
So, thanks for reading my mind.
Stay tuned for my printed map.
- [Is] Favorite natural site
on each continent you've been to?
- Oh, natural. Okay.
Natural site...(deep inhale)
Grand Canyon in North America,
or Zion, honestly, Zion.
For Europe, the Alpujarras,
the mountains in Spain
that are very beautiful,
lots white villages.
For Switzerland,
it is the Jungfrau Valley.
In A-, in Asia,
it is the,
I mean, the mountains outside Taipei
are just beautiful or Southern India.
And then for...
- [Is] South America?
- South America, I would say
a little village called
Villa Rica in Peru.
The continent of Africa, I would say the,
the Westernmost point of Africa,
which is in Senegal.
There's just immense beauty
on the coastline there.
And then, I haven't been to Oceania yet
or Australia
and I have not been to Antarctica.
- [Is] What are some long-term goals
you would like to
achieve with Bright Trip?
- I mean, Bright Trip, which is
the company that we started
a year and a half ago,
is basically what I do on this channel,
but applied to a ton of people
making that type of work,
and doing it for travel.
So it's if you're going
on a trip to Senegal
or you're going on a trip to Japan,
you can watch a, an explainer course
that gives you the in-depth version
of how to do that place
and how to understand its story.
I want tons of people to be able to
make this sort of content.
And my dream is to have
hundreds of courses
that aren't made by me,
but are made by other people
about their experiences
and their knowledge.
So that's what we're building.
That's Bright Trip, brighttrip.com.
- [Is] What have you
learned about yourself
as you've grown your channel?
- Oh, man.
I have learned huge things
about myself in the past year.
Number one is, I just
like telling stories.
♪ I'm the storyteller, and
my stories must be told ♪
- I just am the guy who wants
to just sit down and write,
and animate, and look at
cuts, and play with music.
Like, I am not grand strategist
when it comes to building the business,
and Is really is that person.
She knows how to think about
building and growing and strategizing.
She's the reason I've
hired everyone I've hired.
We now have a team of eight people
working on the channel
and that's all because of Is.
If it were just me, I would
still be making all the videos,
start to finish, myself
and I would be not growing a business.
And so, I've learned that
I love to tell stories,
I will always be a part of that.
I don't want anything to do
with the business side of it,
as long as I can keep telling stories.
- [Is] How did you find
your videography aesthetic
and, and include animation in there?
Like, why?
- It comes from a lot of influences.
Number one was just my own
interest in visuals as a kid.
I always would film things and
bring it up on the VCR and
like, look at what I filmed,
and sort of enjoyed looking
at it and the art of it.
I think maps became a
huge part of my life,
just as a teenager, I
always looked at maps
and I think that paper map feel
made its way into my style
- Paper maps.
- I think that the growth
of informal filmmaking,
with the 5D Mark II back in 2008...
(heartbeat)
- (echoed whispering) 5D Mark II...
- ...to Casey Neistat,
who really made his work
look almost accidental and DIY.
(crash)
And then I think the
biggest, most important one,
as it pertains to this channel,
is what I learned at Vox,
specifically from Joss Fong,
about visual explanation.
When you say something, you show it.
And you show it and the writing pairs with
what the visual is.
And that, that seems so simple,
but the way that she taught me
and trained me to, to write in that way
absolutely is the foundation of my,
of my style and my work
and the value of my work, I would say.
If I didn't have that training from Joss,
I probably would still just
be making sort of abstract,
beautiful looking images
and abstract films without
any explanation and
journalism baked into it.
So thank you, Joss, as always.
- [Is] How do you keep up your curiosity?
Are you afraid of burning out
and how do you combat that?
- This is a hard one to answer
because I don't know how
I keep up my curiosity.
I'm just a curious person, you know,
I've just like, it'd be like,
how do you keep up your
love for chocolate?
It's like, I don't know.
I just like chocolate.
(tense music)
- Smells chocolatey, eh?
- It's, that's how I feel about curiosity
is, it's just a deep preference of mine
to be informed about the world
and to do what it takes.
I think that one important
aspect of my curiosity
and my desire to explain things
is that for many years
I felt outside the loop
on understanding, and I felt dumb
and, and unintelligent
because the school system
sort of told me I was.
And so, I think a major thing
that drives my curiosity is
I want to make work that is
how I wish someone had
explained it to me, you know?
And so, that drives a lot of
my, of the work that I do.
But in terms of my
curiosity, I don't know.
Like, why do you like
chocolate? I don't know.
It's like a, it's a deep part
of me, deep part of who I am.
And yes, I'm, I'm always worried
that it's not going to go away,
but I don't think it will.
- [Is] What is your
favorite item of clothing
that is not the orange jacket?
(camera clicking)
(dial-up tones)
- Item of clothing...
I have these shorts from 2006,
when I was a cross country
runner in high school.
They are red and white,
just the color of my high school team,
the Ashland Grizzlies,
and I've had them forever
and I just love them.
And I think I'll always love them.
- [Is] Someone just
really landed a hard ball.
Are you happy?
- (laughing) Jesus...
Oh, man.
It's like (feigned explosion),
point blank, deer-in-the-headlights.
- (in slow motion) Headlights.
- You know, am I happy?
Yes. I mean, I'm, the definition of happy,
when you live with singular experience,
you don't know what happy
is for other people.
So I don't know, I-I'm
stressed about things.
I'm worried about things.
I stress about the future
of my children's lives
and et cetera.
But overall, I am happy
with the life that I have.
And, and that's mainly because I have deep
beautiful relationships
with these people around me
that give a lot of meaning to my life.
I think the work that I do
and the success that I've had
in this work is a, an
amplifier of that happiness.
But I wouldn't say it's the core.
I wouldn't say that it is the foundation.
It is an amplifier.
I feel like a lot of external factors
that aren't relationship-based
can be amplifiers, but I, I'm not sure
that they can be the core because I see,
especially on YouTube
where there's algorithms
and some videos do well,
and some don't (sniffs),
if my happiness were founded
on, on, on this work,
it would be a roller coaster.
And it is sometimes, if I
find myself investing too much
of my worth into this,
it is a roller coaster.
And so I try to invest
in, in my relationships.
And so, yeah, I would say
I'm happy, in a sense.
- [Is] Do you have a team
helping you make videos
or is it just to you?
You seem to be able to create content
with exceptional quality in a short time.
- I have a team.
- And I'm putting together a special team.
- For years, I've been
slowly training people
to think in the way that I think
when it comes to editing and then they've
added their own personalities
into it as well.
And together that's created our style.
I have a team that helps edit and animate,
and more and more will take
on the edits, start to finish.
I won't be jumping in Premiere
nearly as much anymore
as I used to, or After Effects.
Although at After Effects
I still do jump in
and play around because I love it.
I write, though. The writing
is the bottleneck for me.
It's the thing that I, I do
and will probably always
do, to some degree,
because it, it's what I want to say
and how I want to say it.
And I direct, I have a
whole scripting method
that I use to direct the visuals.
- [Is] That kind of
goes with this question,
which is, do you,
do you have the animation
and editing in your mind
before the narration script?
- Yes, absolutely.
So when I'm writing a video,
and this is if you're on Patreon,
I do, I publish all my scripts
and also do behind the
scenes on all this stuff.
So, Patreons, thank you, Patreons.
I have the vision of everything
in my head as I'm writing,
and then editors and animators
who work on my videos will
add their own interpretation.
They'll add their own
version of what I put.
Often, it's super specific,
so they'll put in what I put,
but then other times it's like, they,
it's open to interpretation
and they put in whatever they feel.
So it's a balance there,
but I absolutely, for certain visuals,
have a very specific vision
that I write into these scripts.
- [Is] How do you simplify complex stories
and express it with so much ease?
Was this something
built, like built in you
or have you worked on it?
- I've definitely worked on this craft
of explaining complicated things.
What you need to know is that
when I'm writing a piece,
I am wrestling with the explanation.
I'm wrestling with every single word
because I know that
when you're watching it,
those words are coming by
at a million miles an hour.
Your brain's either going
to ingest them or...
(snaps fingers)
...it's not.
And if it's not, you're not
going to pause and rewind.
You're just going to move onc and be like,
I didn't get that.
So I'm thinking, I need
to make sure every word
that comes out of my mouth is worthy
of this person's (chuckling) brain.
It will sink in and they'll understand.
And so, I'll go over it.
And I'll even belabor
the explanation over,
and repeat myself sometimes
in the name of, of understanding.
I think it's natural in me
because I've always been someone
who wants to teach and explain.
But again, I'm very dyslexic and, that,
I struggled big time in
school because of that.
And so, I always wished
someone would explain it to me.
Once I found out what a black hole was
or what a cell was, I was,
once I found that out,
and understood it in like my adulthood,
I was like, oh, it
wasn't that complicated.
I spent 20 years of my life
feeling like I couldn't
understand anything.
And it's because it was words on a page.
And so, all I needed was this visual.
This visual helps me understand it.
And this really good explanation.
And so, I think I have built a whole world
out of trying to explain things in the way
I wish someone had explained it to me.
That, that summarizes a lot of my style.
So it's very innate in that way
but it's also wrought from
a desire to explain things
in a way that someone can understand it.
Because I hate the feeling
of not understanding,
I hate that feeling.
And that someone's smarter than me
and that they are using
their understanding
to brandish that. It's not a good feeling.
I feel like there's so much of that.
And it's like, let's let everyone
just understand this thing.
- [Is] I was going to ask
if you had a pet peeve,
but...
- (laughs)
- [Is] ...it sounds like
we just heard all about it.
- (laughing) Geez.
Thank you all for being here.
Thank you, Patreons.
Thank you Policygenius
for supporting this video.
And I, next time you see me,
I will, I will be in a
completely different scenario.
We have so many cool
videos coming up in June
about really cool stuff.
And I'm excited to share them with you.
But for now I'm going to go take a nap.
- [Is] If you had any questions
that you didn't answer,
leave them in the comments so
he can answer them next time.
- That's a good, good point.
- [Is] (laughs)
- [Johnny] Bye, everybody.
(laughter)
- Now, if you'll excuse me,
I'm going to hurl.
(reel scratches)